bonsoir james tobin merci d'être avec
nous donc la journée marquée par cette
toute première rencontre entre joe biden
et boris johnson qui on rappelle était
plutôt proche de donald trump
comment laborde et il sait comment
l'at-il abordés selon vous cette
rencontre le premier ministre
britannique
je pense que pour le moment ça a été un
à un un grand succès c'est à dire que
non seulement dubaï n'a été extrêmement
chaleureux et généreux aussi dans les
paroles avec lesquels il a il a décrit
son accueil unis mais toutes les
références que ce soit dans le discours
à la base de mes deux rôles ou dans le
discours ce soir toutes les références à
l'époque de la deuxième guerre mondiale
a cherché la halle rosefelt les
références explicites ce qu'il a fait à
la relation spéciale special chercher
tout ça est extrêmement flatteur pour
boris johnson et pour le peuple
britannique
donc pour le moment c'est un très très
bon début alors il y avait évidemment la
question brûlante un de l'irlande du
nord première déclaration laisse johnson
il a évoqué un terrain d'entente sur
cette question et se dit optimiste
c'est une vraie volonté en tout cas de
la part de ben jonson de gommer d'emblée
les divergences on rappelle que c'est
une question importante
origine de joe biden cette question
garlande du nord oui en fait dubaï avec
des gens on voyait un message bien à
l'as vence en disant qu'il fallait que
la question du protocole et lombez soit
résolu et on arrive en personne il a
apporté
si vous voulez là le message que chaleur
donc on a les deux
de toute façon boris johnson n'a aucun
intérêt
arrêtez les dernières négociations avec
l'union européenne sur le protocole
l'irlande du nord
si si ces négociations ne sont pas
couronné de réussite
c'est très dangereux pour l'état de
l'irlande du nord et donc pour le
gouvernement de monsieur johnson donc il
sait qu'il a intérêt à bien gérer la
question mais nous sommes vraiment dans
les petits détails de cet accord où il
faut déterminer les solutions pratiques
sur les saucisses par exemple où les
chiens pour les aveugles et ainsi de
suite
tout ça c'est très fastidieux mais il
faut passer par la soirée maquereau a
prévenu que le bric site n'était en rien
renégociable ça veut dire clairement qu
aujourd'hui le royaume-uni a vraiment
tout intérêt à très bien s'entendre avec
les états unis un au niveau commercial
on imagine que l'angleterre attend
beaucoup de l'allié américain
sur le plan commercial
je ne sais pas pour l'immédiat je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait un accord
commercial avec les états unis
avant la résolution de la question et
landaises ça c'est parfaitement logique
et c'est là où il ya une certaine
pression pour le moment je pense qu'ils
vont parler bien sûr des taxes
un du monde en développement mais aussi
de questions stratégiques notamment je
pense de la question de la chine la
chine effectivement qui étaient parmi
les grandes obsessions des moments avec
la réussite de joe biden qui veut
montrer une europe soudée justement
vis-à-vis de ces pays on en reparlera